we name one housewife that's in the
media but we have cardi B Nicki Minaj
Alex Cooper from caller Daddy all of
these women are really living out what
feminism wants even when you have a
traditional wife they usually have two
kids they usually got married over the
age of 25.
um half the time they have their kids in
daycare or public schools which is all
feminine and if there's any problems in
their marriage they'll go to therapy
also and again because what is
traditional traditional is family before
everything so you would never send your
kid to daycare or Nanny because family
comes first you would never send your
kid to sports where a team becomes their
family at least especially not the women
because the men are supposed to be
working yeah and